all right like an orange tornado Donald
Trump swept into the NATO summit the
expectation total destruction but hasn't
anyone notice the pattern not the media
who monitored Trump with an infant's
temperament it's always the end of the
world yet why do we always feel fine
could it be because tremendous progress
has been made tremendous progress has
been made everyone's agreed to
substantially up their commitment
they're going to up it at levels that
they've never thought of before never
never so after all the noise
everything's calm again and it seems
like all Trump did was ask the other
guys to pay their fair share
fair share remember when the media loved
that it's only right that we ask
everyone to pay their fair share it was
important for us to make sure that
millionaires and billionaires paid their
fair share making sure the wealthiest
Americans begin to pay their fair share
after that of your allies our media
bristles how dare us rubes ask are more
sophisticated allies to chip in on the
bill especially in public it it's like
when the dinner bill comes it's always
that know-it-all at the table who darts
to the restroom leaving you to be the
jerk to call him on it because he knows
you won't but he never expected that
Trump would be at the table who would do
it to his face because frankly he's our
jerk Germany spends only 1.2 4 percent
of its GDP on NATO which was created to
curb Soviet expansion meanwhile
Germany's pipelining with Putin talk
about Soviet expansion since America is
always left with the bill maybe we can
call Germany out for hiding in the John
doing dirty deals when the check drops
now Trump wants defense spending at 4%
GDP twice what these countries already
fail to me why would he do that maybe to
get them to meet the initial target
could he be a stable genius I'm very
consistent I'm a very stable genius so
after all the Tantrums can't the media
admit that Trump had a point now Putin
is next which means everyone on CNN will
dawn their chicken suits and scream at
the sky telling us it's the end of the
world but only as they
yells Jed another apocalypse averted it
seems I don't understand the outrage
over this I really don't I don't
understand why if there's a country
that's an ally of ours that isn't doing
what they're supposed to be doing and
we're all supposed to be helping each
other out and they're not pulling their
weight in a certain area I get you have
to be a little bit cautious with the
language that you use maybe in the way
you approach it you don't want to
jeopardize those relationships but he's
the president of the United States he is
supposed to put America first he is
supposed to say hey guys look we're all
supposed to be helping each other out
and if you're not giving the percentage
that you're supposed to be giving toward
the spending and we are you need to up
it that's Josh he's like the guy at the
restaurant when the bill comes he
itemizes the bill that's funny though
you know I the media loved when Obama
went on the apology tour and and they
hate this I mean this is just he wants
to strengthen NATO and make sure
everybody has skin in the game I don't I
don't see I don't see why they have a
problem with it at all let me ask one is
this that stereotype realized where you
have the snooty Europeans and the ugly
American who comes over talks about
money and talks about money and jingles
change in his pants we have a stable
genius genius on our team goes over
there and the context is what's missing
I think from Jesse's analysis because
ninety seven to two is what the Senate
voted just this week to say we like NATO
right American public is like 69% NATO
helps us in terms of international
security and guess what we have here in
a situation where the president comes
out and says oh I have persuaded all
these NATO allies now to up their
spending Emmanuel macron comes out and
says no we just said we will hold to our
existing promise and they're lousy
tippers the frame he what he likes NATO
he just thinks he can get a better
project Dana isn't that the key I mean
maybe I'm wrong this is only my
speculation is that to get them to get
to the 2% I mean it's the art of the
deal like the compromise I think what he
is saying
is that if you think that you have a
problem with Russia and I agree with you
yes if he does we'll see right like you
have a problem then you should put more
towards your defense I think though that
has bothered me about this it's not like
there's a big NATO pie the percentages
are but what you spend on your own
defense for your country so it's like
that's why they're a little bit
different the Estonia is GDP yeah 2% of
Estonia is GDP like really much we just
made that in an hour and write States so
it's all like leading up to it I think
on the Putin thing what's very
interesting and I would watch for it is
you had Netanyahu go to Putin the other
day and say I want you to make a deal
with us did you let us deal with Syria
and take you out of the picture and let
us have Iran this isn't that pipeline
thing a little squirrel eat the whole
thing
yes so they have this pipeline should
have gone through Ukraine and said it
goes right through the sea right to
Russia and Ukraine but the part of the
reason the Ukrainians didn't want it is
they didn't want the Russians to have to
get to put their pipeline through the
big you get transmission fees when a
good let me just tell you and also that
deal was struck in 2000 wait all the
trouble so you have a different context
Jesse I agree they should buy it from us
exactly
Ukraine I crane we all crane by the way
do you really want Germany to have a
strong military one
fair point no indeed